[Music]
let's go to jessica in washington dc hey
jessica how are you
hi i'm doing well thank you yeah what's
going on
um i just had a quick question about
some parent plus loans we're paying um
for my husband's education and
they send his his mom's name
um
and it's about 56 000 it's in his
parents name and a really high interest
rate like 7.9
um
we just don't know if we should make
this as part of our baby step two we've
we've paid off our own personal debt and
just bought a house and a 15-year
mortgage like we're really
go cruising through the big steps um but
we just don't know if we should put this
in our name and and uh consider it our
own if we're going to be paying it
jessica how old are you guys
um i'm 29 and he's 30. okay so is this
loan
recent did he like go back to school or
was this from when he was in college you
know 15 years when he was in college
yeah okay
13 he graduated and
what does his parents financial
situation you don't think they're gonna
be able to pay
this loan off or is it is it more of a
is it a financial obligation that you
feel or like an emotional hey this is
basically his loan and we need to we
feel the need to do this emotionally or
is it more financial i would say both we
are in a much better predicament to pay
it and emotionally i mean
he feels like he owes his mom everything
she was she's an amazing mom so we just
want to do this for them
yeah well you know from a
legal standpoint right it is their loan
um that they signed to pay right it's
that's the parent plus loan formula um
but for you guys i mean i think that
there's a level um of dignity you're
giving yourselves of saying hey you know
what we're adults
and
this loan was for him for his education
and yeah legally she's the one that
can take it and all that right that's
what that's what the deal is
but you guys taking it on um
in a way is is very noble it's a way of
taking care of of his mom and like you
said she probably won't be able to pay
it off it's putting her in a situation
and if you guys are able to take it on
um i think that's kind of a beautiful
thing i think that's a that's a gift
to give her and i don't think your your
spirit doesn't sound like you're doing
it out of obligation i think you feel
like you're doing it because this is the
right thing to do would you say
yeah absolutely um so we just don't know
if we should put it in our name or
continue making payments like through
her account
um and if we should add this to our baby
steps to kind of revert back because we
we feel like we're ready to move on to
being step four if we just kind of make
monthly payments on this and not make it
part of our debt but it is our debt
essentially
yeah it is i mean it's just semantics
it's just how you're talking about it
because if you're taking emotional
ownership and you're taking actual
financial payment of it then yes it is
whether or not you want to pretend it's
in your debt snowball or not for the the
step backwards that it feels like um did
you already say this jessica maybe i
missed it but what are the expectations
have you all communicated with
the parents about who is paying it who's
responsible for it
yeah i mean it was not um we just kind
of decided to take it on about two years
ago i'm using pain on it for a while so
i think it's pretty expected that we'll
be paying for it it was just totally but
have you all said that have you have you
all had a conversation like we're going
to take this on and we're going to pay
it off
yeah okay great awesome i just think
that's key because sometimes we can have
different expectations like you guys
expected them to take it back or you
expected it to be split or something
like that so just if if if y'all are all
on the same page from an expectation
standpoint then yeah i love that and if
you can then do it if it sounds to me
and rachel you come in here it sounds to
me that what feels right in your spirit
jessica is to pay it so even if we told
you not to pay it for some reason which
we wouldn't
your spirit is what's telling you what
you need to do like it's like that's
what you feel convicted to do which is
awesome so you need to do
what you feel called to do and and i'll
be honest just because i don't know
the process of putting the loan in your
name i know you asked that versus
keeping it in hers um i would say
if you guys were able to pay this off
quickly
a part of me would say not to mess with
it it doesn't matter keep it in her name
well it adds to the liability you know
of of her if they don't pay it it is
still in her you know i mean there's
just
i mean if you paid off quickly yeah yeah
but yeah you're right if you pay it off
quickly that's what i'm saying i don't
it doesn't
i don't think it really matters that
much in that way so um but i don't know
the process even to direct you in that
so
i would say continue to pay it off but i
would be gazelle and since i would pause
everything um i know you guys haven't
moved quite onto baby step four i don't
think you said so
um yeah i would continue to pay off this
this 56 and you can keep
keep it where it is
rachel i'm curious because i know you
have talked about this a lot dave has
talked about this a lot but um this is a
great question a great example from
jessica and it sounds like everyone's in
a really healthy place sometimes we get
calls and it's not that and it's why i
paid for my
mom or you know i paid for my sister xyz
and
she didn't pay me back and you know i
thought she was going to and we never
and there's just these weird family
dynamics when someone pays for someone
else's something
and i i love jessica's heart because
it's very much like we want to we don't
have to but we want to and it's coming
out of this like joyful heart and it's a
gift or it's a you know it's a
something that everybody's on the same
page how do you advise people when
they're like should i pay for this thing
for a family member like what's the
what's the kind of like framework you
you walk them through to ask if that's
right for you
well i would say the first
step is to think i'm not getting this
money back this is a gift right right
we're not going to lose it out it's not
a debt we're going to loan it out
i would say if there's a a level of
enabling i would push into it um because
what ends up happening is you could end
up harming them more than helping them
that's right exactly um but that's the
beautiful thing when we talk about
living like no one else later you can
live and give like no one else and you
know we get calls that people have paid
off their parents mortgages right like i
mean these insane gifts that you're able
to do for people when you handle your
own money right i mean and jessica's
that right like they they're on baby
step four now and she's like you know
what we're going to take on this debt
but technically his mom's paid for right
yeah it took out but we're going to do
that because it was you know my
husband's education i'm like that's a
gift like what it that that is so
um
so i would just make sure that the
enabling part is not in there um
but also i would say from a spiritual
aspect if you feel the holy spirit you
feel like god's telling you to do
something
yeah that's a great that's a great
checklist as well to say all right all
right we're gonna we're gonna engage
this opportunity to do it um
but i think
understanding and the expectation
because like you said we get so many
calls i've even had friends two
different friends that
their parents took out a loan for
college
they didn't realize it but it was under
their name right
and then they're going to go buy a house
and they pull and they're like you know
and they go and they're like my dad
they're like yeah well you're supposed
to pay on this like i haven't been
paying honest i didn't know it was that
you know you didn't tell me i mean
there's just so much miscommunication
that can happen in families because of
just assuming yeah oh i just assumed you
knew right well how would you assume we
never talked about it so the over
communication part which is why i liked
you pressed jessica on that like that's
a key part whenever you're dealing with
money and family
keeping it clean helps with that
communication clear communication to be
unclear is to be unkind yeah you're not
being kind by just dancing around the
edges and making everything sweet go in
there and and lay down exactly what's
going on yeah um because that truth is
going to help kind of slice through
a lot of the hardship that can be caused
by money and family yeah and uh i love
how we quote this all the time but
george bernard shaw said the biggest
problem with communication is the
illusion that it's occurred i thought
you knew you thought i knew but i said
but you meant and i thought and that's
where so much resentment builds that's
where conflict occurs that's where you
missed each other you had an expectation
they had an expectation there were
different expectations and you never
talked about them and so so much can be
resolved so much conflict
so many uh you know resentment that's
building up could be resolved if you
would just communicate if you would just
say what are your expectations here here
are my expectations here let's get on
the same page before we move forward in
anything by the way that's not just a
money principle that's a life principle